[Music]
welcome to the ted interview i'm chris
anderson
this is the podcast series where i sit
down with a ted speaker and we get to
dive much deeper into their ideas than
was possible during their ted talk
my guest this episode is yuval harari
he's a historian and a futurist and his
books have wowed so many people because
of the sweeping way in which they
connect our past and our future
yuval thinks that humans have gotten to
where we are in large part because of
our ability to
as he puts it create fictions to tell
stories and to share those stories
we can cooperate because we alone of all
the animals on the planet can create and
believe fictional stories a human can
say look there is a god above the clouds
and if you don't do what i tell you to
do after you die god will punish you and
send you to hell
this is something only humans can do
you can never convince a chimpanzee to
give you a banana by promising him that
after you die you'll go to chimpanzee
heaven
no chimpanzee will ever believe such a
story
yuval has a story about the future that
is profound exciting but also unsettling
he thinks the disillusionment that many
of us feel right now is actually to a
large part misconceived it's not that we
shouldn't be worried but we're actually
worried about the wrong things
they'll lie ahead of us
much deeper dangers dangers that
actually could
even spell the end of civilization as we
know it
over the next hour we'll talk about some
of those dangers
and about why yuval thinks we've gotten
to where we are and what we can do to
prepare for the coming challenges
yvonne hirari welcome it's good to be
here
so
you have this extraordinary way of
connecting
history with
every issue that is relevant today i
think and you seem to do it by
the way you describe history as this
history of narratives of the stories
that humans
have told themselves which which i think
you argue is really humanity's
superpower
i'm curious
to hear what you think of the narrative
we're telling ourselves today this
basically i think in your in your book
21 lessons of the 21st century you talk
about a disillusionment that's happened
how would you describe that narrative
that we're telling ourselves today
we don't have a narrative
i mean we are in this
quite unique and frightening situation
when we don't have a story
to explain to ourselves what is
happening in the world and where we are
heading
uh in the 20th century we had three big
narratives three big stories that really
explained everything
the past the present the future you had
the fascist story which said that the
whole of human history is a struggle
between nations
and one human group one nation one race
will violently dominate the entire world
and the second story was the communist
story
communism said no no no history is not a
struggle among nations history is a
struggle among classes everything that
happened for thousands of years is a
struggle among classes
and the future the communist vision for
the future was that one social system
will dominate the whole world ensuring
equality between all people even at the
price of freedom
and then the third story was the liberal
story which basically said history is
not a struggle between nations or
between classes it's a struggle between
liberty and tyranny
and the liberal vision for the future
was a peaceful cooperation between
different groups of people
with some inequality but with maximum
freedom with freedom is the main thing
and we can take inequalities as the
inevitable price of that
and
you can see the 20th century is a
struggle between these three stories
one by one they get knocked out fascism
is knocked out in the second world war
then the cold war knocks out communism
and at the end of the 20th century we
reached the end of history when the
liberal story is the only one remaining
and
so so we had these three stories and
then two stories and then just one story
there is just one story that explains
everything this is the most reassuring
situation and then it collapses which is
what is happening over the last 10 years
five years
and we don't have a new big story that
explains what is happening and where we
are going so
talk about the current disillusionment i
mean what caused the blowing up of the
liberal story and actually while before
we go too far down the street i just
want some more clarity on the liberal
story because the word liberal is
understood differently by other people
in the uk there's a party called the
liberals yeah there's it's understood
differently by liberal you mean the term
pretty broadly in a way that actually
encompasses for example both george w
bush exactly
in historical terms he is a liberal most
trump supporters are also liberals in
the historical sense i mean i mean i
know that in the us when people say
liberal they have in mind gay marriage
gun control abortion all these things
but historically speaking it's much much
broader define it oh okay maybe maybe
i'll say something about the word
liberal it simply comes from liberty
it's the idea that liberty is the most
important value in the political sphere
in the economic sphere in the personal
sphere
so in the political sphere and from a
broad historical perspective thinking in
terms of centuries and not decades if
you think
that
political power should come from the
people and not from some king or from
god or something like that then you're a
liberal and then you have the economic
field
and there the idea is that people should
be free to choose their professions
their products what to buy what to work
economic liberty if you think that
people should have the freedom to choose
their own professions their own careers
you are an economic liberal
so you have the political field the
economic field and then you have the
personal field
so here the test is if you think that
people should be free to choose whom to
marry
then again you're liberal this is where
it gets
confusing i think the term liberal a
little bit for some people because
people there's a lot of conservatives
who would accept the first two
definitions of liberal would embrace
that but um perhaps until recently
many of those people would not have
accepted liberal guidance on on the very
personal side and so yeah i mean but
even if you look at
the personal field i think even most
hardline republicans
are in favor of marrying from love and
from your own personal choices and are
not in favor of fixed marriages
i think that most republican voters did
not marry somebody who was chosing for
them without their consent and
participation by their parents or by the
elders
so when you get to something like gay
marriage if my choice is to marry
somebody from my own gender
then some people say okay that's where
the line i draw the line
but compared to the situation a century
ago
i think that most republican voters a
century ago would have been considered
like extreme hippies
they would have been like on the extreme
liberal
end of the of the spectrum so this
definitely on the personal sphere
there's been this massive shift of um
opinion over time and um
you can think of the liberal story as a
broad one there's lots of detail in
there but basically a version of that
story com encompassing politics
economics and personal yes became the
winning ideology of say from 1990 or
whatever onwards but um but it kind of
you know after 20 years boom ran into
massive problems describe what happened
what are the reasons is difficult to say
especially because many of the promises
of kind of the liberal story were
fulfilled the world is still full of
problems but compared to any previous
time in history
according to many measurements we never
had it better i mean if people think no
liberalism has done a really bad job we
want to go back to some prayer liberal
golden age i would just like to know
which year they have in mind if you
think the world of the early 21st
century is a bad place to live in
what are you dreaming about the 1950s
the 1850s are you drinking drinking
about going back to the 13th century if
you look at statistics about things like
child mortality like uh epidemics like
famine
for humans not for the planet not for
the ecological system but for human
beings uh the early 21st century is the
best time to live so as a historian
almost what i hear you saying is there's
almost a human psychological bug where
we're widely prone to nostalgia and to
actually to false
stories about the past we we
don't remember the bad stuff we have a
tendency to focus on recent problems
that hit us now and we're not really
comparing
like with like and and now that can be
dangerous actually
yeah i mean if you say if you like
family values
just consider going back 200 years to a
situation when you have six kids and
four of them die before they reach 20.
if you care about family and about
children would you like to live in such
a world
and i think most people won't but they
just don't remember
because they weren't alive
so they don't take this into account
and
when i try to understand so what is
the the deep reason for this
disillusionment and backlash against the
the liberal order
so one option is that this is actually
limited to
largely
the western core countries
were in relative terms even though their
situation also improved in comparison to
people in in india or in china
the gap has shrunk
and
because it was still the most powerful
countries in the world especially the us
when people in the u.s
feel miserable
the entire world shakes
the world feels the pain of people in
kentucky and pennsylvania far far more
than it feels the pain of people in
brazil or in india is that because media
stories originate from the us or it's
not just media you know the us is a
powerful country in the world in
economic terms
in military terms in cultural terms
so
the resentment
of people here
translates into political and economic
steps which have a huge impact on all
the world whereas if you live in
sudan
and you are resentful there is whatever
you do it it's unlikely to have such an
impact on the rest of the world so if
people in in sudan or people in the
philippines feel pain
the world usually ignores them but if
people in kentucky or people in indiana
feel pain the entire world
uh pays attention and you have now this
like people in silicon valley people in
the in the top universities they are
constantly thinking
why are people in indiana and kentucky
resentful and how much of the
explanation of that is just almost the
simple economic one that the world came
to believe in free trade almost like a
religion it was like this is the way
that you maximize overall economic
growth so all these trade agreements
were put into a place to allow that
pipes effectively were connecting
the us and europe with the rest of the
world and it allowed the immediate sort
of outsourcing of a lot of
of jobs so that um
hundreds of millions of jobs were
created in the developing world but they
probably displaced
tens of millions of jobs in europe and
the us and that's and led to this sort
of plateauing of income and and and hope
for the future that has been ended up
being quite quite destructive is that is
that a core part of the narrative there
i think that's part of the story that
you know for
two centuries britain and the united
states and other western powers have
pushed the entire world
in the name of free trade and
globalization because it worked very
well for people in britain and the us
and suddenly when it works well for
china and india but works less well for
the usa they say no no no i forgot about
it all the stuff we said about free
trade and globalization we don't want it
anymore
so that's that's part of the story
but i i still think it there is
something deeper than that
i don't know i mean we need a lot of of
research and empirical data to back up
or disprove what i am about to say
so take it just as an idea as a
hypothesis not as kind of a of a
full-fledged explanation
but i think part of what is going on on
maybe a deeper level of of of the human
mind
is that
people sense
a lot of people sense that they are
being left behind and left out
of the story
even if their material conditions are
still relatively good
in the 20th century what was common to
all the stories the liberal the fascists
the communists is that the big heroes of
the story were the common people
not necessarily all people
but if you lived say i don't know in the
soviet union in the 1930s
life was very grim
but when you looked at the propaganda
posters
on the walls that depicted the glorious
future
you were there
you looked at the posters which showed
steel workers and farmers in in in
heroic poses and it was obvious that
this is the future
now when people
look at the posters on the walls or
listen to ted talks
they hear a lot of you know these big
ideas
and big words about machine learning and
genetic engineering and blockchain and
globalization and and
they are not there
they are no longer part of the story of
the future
and i think that if i again this is an
hypothesis
if i try to understand
and to connect to the deep resentment
of
people in many places around the world
part of of what might be going there is
people
realize and they are correct in thinking
that that the future doesn't need me
you have all these smart people in
california and in new york and in
beijing
and they are planning this amazing
future with artificial intelligence and
bioengineering and global connectivity
and whatnot and they don't need me so
maybe if they are nice they will throw
some crumbs my way like universal basic
income
but it's it's much worse psychologically
to feel that you are useless than to
feel that you are exploited so talk
about this because this is this is one
of the key
ideas that you have been extremely
articulate about talk about how how you
see technology shifting how things work
and actually realizing those fears or
risking realizing those fears even more
deeply than you think people feel so on
on one level
you know it's the economic and military
realities
if you go back to the middle of the 20th
century and it doesn't matter if you're
in the united states with roosevelt or
if you're in germany with hitler or if
you're in in the ussr with stalin and
you think about building the future
then your building materials are those
millions of people
who are working hard in the factories in
the farms the soldiers in the you need
them you don't have any kind of future
without them
and now fast forward to to the early
21st century when
we just don't need
the vast majority of the population
because
because uh
the future is about developing more and
more sophisticated technology like again
artificial intelligence bioengineering
most people don't contribute anything to
that except perhaps for their data
and whatever people are still doing
which is useful these technologies
increasingly will make redundant and
will make it possible to replace the
people and that's obviously you know
there's a lot of debate um about this
some people
feel
that
actually
technologies including artificial
intelligence
will empower people simply to do more
more interesting work i mean clearly
technology can empower there's you know
a radiologist who you know here's an ai
that detects um
patterns of cancer better than they do
but perhaps they can become a sort of
strategist and sort of um you know move
their work to a higher level and figure
out what is the wisest
diseases to direct radiology into and
and use these use these things as tools
and therefore the work actually gets
more interesting
what's the the counter warning to that i
agree there will be
many new and exciting jobs for humans
the problem is that it's not clear that
many humans will be able to do them
because they will require high skills
and
a lot of education
so a lot of humans will be left behind
even if there are new jobs again taking
the historical perspective if you look
look back at what's happening in the
1920s and 1930s
so you have technology coming in and
displacing a lot of people from
traditional jobs in farming
so you don't need a hundred farmers on
this on this farm you just need two
tractors and a couple of mechanics and
drivers that's it
so you have 90 farmers displaced but
then they just move to the city they
move to detroit or they move to
stalingrad and start working in the
tractor factory
in in that way they are still part of
the future
but what we are talking about now with
the rise of ai and machine learning and
all that is that
a lot of jobs will be replaced and the
new jobs will demand high skills and a
lot of retraining when you left your
farm
in i don't know minnesota and move to
detroit to work in the factory it's
always difficult to change your
profession in your life
but
to learn the job of a factory hand in in
this big factory in detroit you could do
it at age 35 or 45 in a couple of weeks
or a couple of months and you will be
okay
and similarly if you lose your job in
the factory and you move to the
supermarket
it's still possible
to do that without a lot of education
and without a lot of free training
but if you lose your job as a truck
driver or as a factory worker and people
come and say oh but wonderful we have
all these new jobs uh engineering
software in california or building
virtual reality games
how are you going to do that
so again trying to desperately to sort
of apply some sort of more hopeful spin
on that
and in fact you do this yourself in your
book at one point um a lot of the jobs
that are being displaced are actually
kind of boring jobs they don't really
tap into the core of what the human is
they they they kind of treat humans a
bit as sort of
robotic things that you pay the money
and and they will do the same thing
again and again and you know we can
aspire to more than that
um so the question is is there more that
you you can do and certainly you know
due to the lens you talked about about
existing jobs you can see them sort of
um being divided up between you know
technology and super skilled humans and
so that's scary but but when you step
back
i mean there's no shortage of things
that need to be done i mean apart from
anything else you know the world's full
of millions of lonely people right right
now um people are really good at making
lonely people not feel lonely if they
want to and pretty much anyone can can
do that you know communities are a mess
pretty much anyone who lives somewhere
could do in principle something to make
a community better they could
paint a fence or or you know do some
voluntary service or whatever i i wonder
to what extent
we're just gonna have to completely
rethink what it is to work what it is to
live and and and find different stories
that perhaps we all have to to start to
figure out a way of taking away this
sort of jobs as the central goal of an
economy and and find some other language
yeah already find out what a job is
if we can redefine
building communities
or raising kids
as a very important job and maybe it is
the most important job of all and pay
for that
then many of these dystopian scenarios
will not come true the question is is
society willing to switch its
definitions and especially pay for these
things um yes i mean if if we can do
that then that's a much brighter future
uh so so we have the path of retraining
people
which cost a lot of money and effort we
have the path of
recognizing activities like community
building and like raising families as
jobs that
maybe the government is paying for and
that also solves a lot of the problems
but for that we need a new economic and
social model
so i'm definitely not saying that things
are hopeless there is nothing that can
be done to to stop the worst case
scenarios there is there are many things
we can do
but it's not going to be easy
because we need a new economic and
social model so yes so this question of
who pays and how seems crucial because
um
in the course to this future
certainly more wealth will be created
but it's going to be aggregated by the
companies who are using the technology
you know they're losing workers and jobs
making their products more profitably
there's there's more wealth there but
there's no agreement on on how that
wealth could ever move to for example
pay a mother or someone who was working
in a in a community do you see
any
solution to that problem other than
somehow
government's just
insisting on on greater
tax distribution from from the very
world traditional role of government
to
when the market isn't efficient enough
in redistributing the the wealth then
this is the job of the of the government
how exactly to do that i'm not an
economist so i don't know
how to answer that it's basically a
political question we need some
political consensus around that but i
would say that the biggest problem by
far
is not on the national level it's on the
global level
i think that americans will be okay and
i think also that the chinese will be
okay because the usa and china are
leading this revolution and they will
dominate the probably the economy in in
the coming decades and more and more
wealth will flow to the us and to china
um so there's still going to be
political battles within the united
states about how exactly to redistribute
the wealth but they have something to
redistribute
if you think about other countries if
you look down south at mexico at
honduras el salvador brazil i think this
journey is far far worse
i mean i can easily envision a future in
which the government taxes
uh the the tech giants in california
to pay mothers in pennsylvania and in
indiana i don't see a future when they
take some of that money and send it to
honduras or mexico or brazil
and so the question is what will the
people there do
so if people now in honduras work as
textile workers and truck drivers and
these jobs are gone because in 20 years
or 30 years it's cheaper to produce
textiles in the u.s than in honduras
because you cut the human element out of
the equation
so what will people in honduras do
i mean i've heard a few
tech optimists talk about the the
possibility for
many millions of jobs being created
basically to help train the um
you know the the algorithms the the
artificial intelligence that we're
creating like it only gets smart by by
virtue of exposure to millions and
millions of data points and many of
those have to be
input by humans so that they reflect our
our insights our our knowledge or
whatever but it it doesn't like it feels
like that
even if that is something it won't be
something forever that that technology
goes through a cycle like ai's get to a
point where initially they they rely on
machine learning and then at some point
they they kind of teach each other or
they just you know they learn from their
own simulation even that i guess there
will again there will be a lot of jobs
but were
i mean there will be a lot of jobs in
the ai industry but i guess most of
these jobs will be in california and not
in honduras or mexico so it's it's not
really a relevant answer it's not really
a relevant solution i mean you still
need the data the data points as you say
to train the ai at least for some period
but here the danger is that we might
seem a kind of data colonization
a little parallel to what we've seen
with the industrial revolution i mean
the model in the 19th century
let's say for britain and its colonies
is that you grow cotton in egypt
you send the raw cotton from egypt to
britain
they're the really important and and
profitable business of producing
textiles this was the high tech of the
19th century was the textile industry so
you send the raw materials of cotton
from egypt to manchester you produce the
shirt in manchester and then you send it
back to egypt to be sold and most of the
profits are of course in manchester and
we might see the same thing with the
data economy
that you harvest data let's say in
mexico
you send the raw data to california
it's being processed there
the uh high-tech products of ai are
being produced in california and then
you send back the finished good to be
sold in mexico and the vast majority of
profits are therefore in california
and the only thing that the the data
colony contributes is the initial data
which it has no control over and
therefore it gets a very small part of
the profits
so there's obviously a huge amount of
concern um about this right now that um
data has become without any of us
noticing this sort of um almost secret
currency of the the modern economy and
and we've been gayly accepting all these
free services not realizing that we're
we're giving up our our data and
granting enormous power um and uh you
know wealth to
a few companies perhaps governments um
do you recommend or see any way through
this where
it feels like in principle there's a
mental flip that can be made it said
that actually everyone
in the world even if they have no money
are actually a source of
value
from their data they have they actually
are an amazing data set even if they
don't have any spending habits to look
at just their dna their their health
their condition in principle there's
enormous value that the rest of humanity
could benefit from if we could figure
out a way of
attributing the value that we get from
data back to that individual it could
actually be an enormous
impetus for
economic growth and perhaps part of the
process for not creating a useless class
after all
have you heard anyone talking
convincingly about how that might be
achieved
yeah there is a lot of talk now about
ownership of data and how to ensure that
people not just own their data but
profit from their data being used there
there is talk about a data tax that part
of the issue is that i mean we are used
to an economy in which currency in which
money dollars euros yens is the main
thing that is uh being exchanged all the
time but we might be moving to a world
in which the main thing that is being
exchanged in more and more interactions
is only information
so if you're thinking in terms of taxing
dollars you're missing most of what is
happening in the economy
and it's not just okay let's try to put
a dollar value on the information being
transmitted again you're missing the
main point don't put a dollar value in
it put an information value in it and
maybe we need to have an information tax
which is not only a tax on information
it's a tax in information you need to
pay in information
uh and we still don't have kind of the
even the the conceptual framework to
deal with such an an economy i mean you
couldn't figure out by implication
approximations for the for the value of
people's data and if you look at a
company like facebook you know it's it's
something like a 55 billion dollar
revenue corporation
that comes from
2.3
billion users i mean in in very rough
average terms it's making 25
per user so there is there is already
the market is is implying certain values
and what i what i wonder is is whether
given the pressure on tech companies now
and the sort of the growing suspicion
and the risk of
government action and so forth whether
some of them might be persuaded or
seduced into
into redefining their contract with
their users and actually saying
you know here's the deal we know that
you are bringing us huge huge value we
are giving you a service and we and um
so we're already giving you that but we
may not be fully reflecting the value of
the data you're giving us we will be
more transparent about this you will
have your own data account and i i feel
like at some point just as people move
towards bank accounts containing money
at some point there's going to need to
be
you know people if people feel control
over their data i think the whole
conversation changes now we don't it's
very hard to conceptualize what it means
to to own and control your data we have
thousands of years of experience in
ownership of land so it's easy to
conceptualize i own this piece of land i
build a fence around it there's a gate
i decide who goes in who goes out very
easy to conceptualize what does it mean
that i own let's say that my medical
data my dna like my most private data
possible my dna code
it's mine okay what does it mean
i mean unlike land which you have just
one copy of a field it's in one place
you can't move it you can't transmit it
nothing with dna okay i have a printout
of my dna wonderful it doesn't mean
anything i mean there could be a billion
copies of my dna in all kinds of clouds
and and computers and whatever
it can be
used in so many ways which i don't
understand
so we we are very far from understanding
what it means to own your your dna and
to have
reasonable models for how to allow
usages that i want like access to my
doctor from usages that i don't want uh
so so this is one problem the other
problem is that
we are now in a situation where the the
data of individual people is very
valuable because it is used to hack the
humanity and to train ai but this is not
going to stay like this for long once
the ai is trained and once humanity is
hacked the data of individual people is
going to decrease drastically and it's
important because we already figured out
this animal so the the next billion
people we don't really need their data
anymore not not as much now is the
critical time
and
the really important thing about what's
being accumulated especially in the us
and in china
is um the ability to hack human beings
and this is worth
trillions and trillions
not billions so that this is an alarming
phrase right the ability to hack human
beings give an example of that what
you're talking about
in the abstract the ability to hack
human beings means the ability to
understand humans better than they
understand themselves
which means being able to predict their
choices better than they can predict
their choices being able to manipulate
their emotions being able to make
decisions for them now it should be very
clear we are not talking about knowing
humans perfectly that's absolutely
impossible never going to happen
we're just talking about the ability to
know you better than you know yourself
which is not so difficult because most
people know very little about themselves
and by the way that's not all bad right
for technology to know that i mean let's
say i'm feeling cranky
and suddenly up on my screen it pops up
a note saying hey go to the fridge and
drink product x you know and you drink
it and oh i feel better that's that's
awesome i did not know that my problem
was this particular deficiency you
didn't drink enough you're dehydrated
it's very simple
so so i mean but part of it is good and
and some of what frustrates me about the
current conversation is that you know
that talks about ooh the risk of you
know behavioral manipulation or the rest
of it is that this has been part of
economic life for years like the the
amount that television companies
extracted per
hour of user attention
could be higher than facebook and google
and so forth are extracting
now
it's not completely new nothing is ever
completely new in history there are
always precedents
so people talk about genetic engineering
well we have been breeding cows and
chickens for thousands of years so
what's new
um there there is something new what's
new i mean maybe to imagine it the
bordeaux line is the skin
previously
almost all the information gathered on
you was outside your skin where you go
what you buy what you watch what you
press on your tv what you press on your
keyboard this is the the information
that flowed but the future is about
going under your skin and looking
directly at what is happening in your
heart in your brain what is your blood
pressure which part of your brain are
activated now and this can be done
either with invasive
technologies like
electrodes implanted inside your body
but more and more with external devices
from a ring or a bracelet on your arm
which measures biometric points of
information
or there are now devices that just by
looking at your face from a camera they
can tell what's happening to your blood
pressure or your heart rate things like
that and this is extremely good clues
for understanding your emotional state
so it can go in the direction of
you know full-blown totalitarian regimes
like north korea forcing every citizen
in say 10 years or 20 years to wear a
biometric bracelet which constantly
monitors not where you go and what you
say it monitors what's happening in your
heart and in your brain if you walk into
a room and there is a picture of kim
jong un on the wall and the bracelet
picks up the the signs of anger because
it has access to your brain uh that's
very bad news for you
even george orwell's 1984 they couldn't
really get into your brain there was
still this sphere of of a private world
and and this is about to disappear in
the west
the main concern now is what is known as
surveillance capitalism
that okay
it's not a kind of dictator that that
spies on your brain but you have all
these corporations and maybe all these
government agencies
which are monitoring what's happening
inside your body
i mean
what does it mean to live in a world
when your inner reality is so completely
exposed i mean i don't know what you
make of the the term surveillance
capitalism it strikes me as a super
powerful
label to denigrate this whole tendency
or you know to use data for uh to create
economic value if you like um the
companies who are behind it i dare say
would say you know what you're kind of
misunderstanding it that's what it's
like when it's misused but really we
think of it as empowerment capitalism
like in your mind what is what is the
trade-off between the good potential and
the evil potential of this there is
enormous good potential we could provide
the best healthcare in the world and the
cheapest healthcare in the world for
billions of people
uh with this kind of technology and this
is why it's so tempting
if there was no
no good side then it was very easy let's
just not do it but there are enormous
beneficial
and there are also great dangers i mean
it's easy to think in terms of oh you
have all these evil corporations or
governments which will abuse this power
in order to manipulate and control
people in horrible ways
intellectually it's it's easy to grasp
that
that's that's wrong we should prevent it
but the really difficult stuff is what
happens if it's not abused
what happens if there is a system
that monitors me monitors my heart my
brain all the time
and is is relatively benign
and is it is used to provide me not only
with better healthcare but with constant
guidance in life
in almost every decision i make
we tend for thousands of years to view
life as a drama of decision making
life is a journey we reach intersection
after intersection we need to make
decisions financial decisions romantic
decisions political decisions what
happens
if in more and more intersections you
just rely on the advice of this
algorithm that knows you so well and is
really a benign algorithm
so it's it you know in the financial
realm
i need to make decisions about where to
invest my money let's say
but this algorithm knows me so well that
when i'm about to make a wrong decision
like i read something on the news i'm
frightened let's sell all my portfolio
and the algorithm knows oh this is a bad
decision your mind is now being
irrational you shouldn't do it
and we learned from experience that this
second brain
that follows me is usually better than
my
organic brain
so i give the bank
an order
if what i tell you conflicts with what
this
uh second brain the algorithm tells you
don't do what i tell you do what the
algorithm is telling you if you do what
i tell you i'll sue you
because i know that the algorithm is
better than me
so you you're on the phone with your
banker and you're screaming sell my
portfolio and the banker says no no no
no you told us not to believe you if the
algorithm says no and we believe the
algorithm and maybe after two hours you
come down and you say ah that's so good
that the banker didn't listen to me now
what happens when the same thing
also repeats itself in the romantic
field
that you want to marry somebody and the
algorithm says no that's a bad idea you
should marry somebody else
and we learn by experience to trust the
algorithm i mean what kind of life is it
when more and more of these decisions
are taken by the algorithms we have no
religious artistic or philosophical
model for understanding such a life so
talk more about this like what do you
have any guidelines to suggest about
the things that are precious that we
must hold on to and actually must not
even start the process of outsourcing to
technology
that's the big question one of the big
problems is how do you define the goal
the financial algorithm that's easy i
want more money
so if you define the goal in in such
simple terms the algorithm knows what to
do when it when you reach something like
the romantic field or like what to study
in university
then
who defines the goal now part of the
problem is that who defines the goal
today i mean how do i define today my
romantic goals or my career goals i mean
it's not that humans are doing it
perfectly now and the algorithms will do
much worse jobs humans are doing a
terrible job now
that's true
so
you know it goes back to the most
ancient philosophical and spiritual
questions
of getting to know yourself of what is
good what is the good life
and i i say it a lot in these days that
ancient philosophical questions are now
becoming practical questions of
engineering so if you lived in ancient
greece or ancient india and you uh have
this debate about what is the good life
or what is a good relationship i don't
know socrates and then his his fellow
athenians discussing this
so
most people
aren't involved in this discussion
and they just live their life in any any
way that they i mean in a haha way they
survive yeah they somewhat mellow
through
and there is an even deeper issue here
which is that self-reflection
and self-exploration is just
much more difficult and painful
than people often imagine
they think oh okay we'll have more time
and technology will help us and we'll
explore ourselves and this will be
wonderful
they imagine themselves like again in
ancient athens walking with socrates and
having these interesting discussions or
sitting for meditation and having all
these
experiences of bliss and oneness with
the universe and wonderful
and
part of the problem and part of the
reason that until today most people did
not embark
on a serious journey of self-exploration
during their life is that it's far far
more complicated and painful from that
you start exploring yourself you
discover many things you don't like
about yourself you don't have these
experiences of bliss and oneness with
the universe well maybe sometimes you do
but most of the time you have these
experiences of pain and anger and
loneliness and all kinds of things that
you don't want to confront they are
there inside
so
i think we reach a point in human
history when technology is forcing us
to do this inner spiritual quest all we
are going to pay a much higher price
for not knowing ourselves than ever
before and this is not going to be easy
well you you strongly recommend
meditation it's something that's become
a huge part of your life
um talk talk about that well i i
meditate i do the pasta meditation which
i've learned from sn goenka i meditate
for two hours every day almost every day
that's an amazing time
investment i mean you really worthy
my yearly vacation is to go on a long
retreat of between say 30 days and 60
days i just came back last month from a
60 days meditation retreat give us give
me one like a sense of an insight that
you got during that 60 days
or just something that that justified to
you the value of that that time
well
you can't understand what's happening
today in the world with the attention
economy if you don't observe what's
happening to your own attention every
moment
that like the simplest
meditation instruction is just you know
the simplest thing in the world just
bring your attention to your breath
and just feel when the breath is coming
in and when the breath is going out and
do that for a few minutes
it's not a breath exercise you're not
trying to control the breath you just
try to feel to notice oh now the breath
is coming in and now the breath is going
out that's it
and this was like when i went to my
first meditation course this was the
instructions on the first evening
and i was absolutely shocked that i
can't do it for more than 10 seconds
without my attention wandering away
anyone who wants to understand the
debate today about the attention economy
and what's happening with
twitter and youtube and facebook and all
that if you don't take the time
to observe your own attention in in in
real life in actual experience you won't
understand that
and to realize you know i was doing my
phd in oxford i thought i was a very
smart person i have full control of my
life nobody can manipulate me and i
couldn't focus my attention
for 10 seconds on my own breath without
some thought emotion memory popping up
and hijacking my attention to some
some some story some fantasy
and it made me really i have no idea
what is actually happening in my mind
i've almost no control over my attention
and that's kind of the beginning of the
journey
to what extent eval is our very language
misleading here like all of our language
is about you me you know it's my
attention you say know thyself
and we often say things like you know
that's just who i am but but
for me it's very helpful to think of
myself as this sort of um
chaotic mix of personalities ideas
thoughts battling you ouch in there this
is kind of like this mad
you know
wriggling
wriggling mess of of all these different
hopes and insights and thoughts and um
and different situations empower
different parts of me exactly um and
parts of me i i don't like very much and
you espouse this really
powerfully in the book that part of the
insight of meditation is the sort of
gradual letting go of sense of self
and a kind of
almost a humility that there's just a
lot more going on in there and our
language is deceiving us a lot a lot of
the time yeah language and religion and
ideology
deceive us they give us this idea of a
unitary entity
that's me
and encourage us to identify with
whatever thought or emotion that pops up
in the mind
if i think something well this is me i
think this i chose to think this thought
it reflects who i am if i feel some
emotions the same thing it's i chose to
feel that if i choose to buy something
to do something all that's my free will
and
when you meditate and you explore what's
actually happening inside you realize
this is a complete illusion
i have very little control usually over
many of the processes inside me so let's
say i sit for meditation for one hour
and i want to experience this peace and
tranquility i tell myself oh you came
here to to meditate to relax to to
experience peacefulness and oneness so
just let all the thoughts go away and
just focus on your breath and i do that
for 10 seconds and then something pops
up like i published an article and there
was some other professor who criticized
it and this comes in the mind and i
become very angry and i i said no that's
not the right time to say i want peace
now let's go away
and it comes back again and again and
then something about the israeli
election which really upsets me comes up
and i lose my temp and i have all these
uh dystopian scenarios about this will
happen and i tell myself stop all this
noise i just want some peace and at the
end of the one hour
i say oh this was a terrible hour of
meditation i couldn't get any peace but
actually it was a wonderful hour of
meditation i
actually observe what's happening inside
and how little control i have over these
things and i also observe the kind of
buttons and and levers that outside
forces can pull inside my mind this is
how it works
okay so let's let's try and connect some
of the dots here um you think that where
technology is going the issues that it's
pushing us to contemplate means that
it's essential that we know ourselves
better we have to stop there if we don't
know ourselves better we will not even
be able to have the conversation around
what do we outsource to technology and
what do we absolutely not you know if
we're not careful we will outsource the
things that are most
precious to us and one of the key
conversations therefore about the future
which needs to be anchored in this
better sense of who we are
is
data yes and again connecting the dots
i don't want anybody to see what i just
told you i mean this experience of
sitting there for one hour with all
these crazy thoughts and emotions in my
mind
i don't want anybody to access that
because i know that if somebody could
access that
they could manipulate me in ways which
were never possible before in history
and i don't want my spouse to be really
able to see what's happening in my mind
i don't want my neighbor because there
is such a crazy world inside
and my power over it is so limited
that it will be very very dangerous
to allow outsiders this kind of access
whether a government whether a
corporation whether an organization it's
a it's very delicate
so
there's one thing that comes out in your
book that i found extremely
powerful and helpful which is that you
point out that um
even though technology is showing signs
of being more intelligent than us in
many ways
it's not showing any sign at all of
being sentient are you feeling anything
um the assumption in a lot of scientific
writing a lot of thought about ai is
that of course those things
must go together historically that's
been the case but i've seen more and
more
deep thinkers
actually so that that's not clear like
if the ability to feel something was
just a consequence of complex
information processing
then
google would already be conscious
probably it's got so much you know going
on there so is there any scenario where
we could write ourselves back into this
story in quite an important way as being
the only things in the universe that we
know of that are actually capable of the
things that matter most in the universe
i.e
love joy creativity the sort of that
feeling of peace you talked about
technology can't advise us on what are
the things deepest in our hearts we
should not let it we should retain
control in fact make our technology in
service to those things and in a sense
the relationship between technology and
us that it should regard sentient things
as gods
that have superpowers it knows nothing
of no is that is that ridiculous i think
that the question of sentience and
consciousness is the most important
question in in this regard and it's the
greatest riddle
in science we don't understand
consciousness we don't understand
sentience uh it's not just humans of
course it's also other animals we don't
understand the consciousness and
sentience of monkeys of pigs of cows
and it is the most important question we
face
the thing is that engineers and
investors are impatient people
they can't wait until we figure out this
thing of consciousness
so they use proxies like okay we want to
improve human experience what does it
mean we don't understand so let's put a
proxy on it time in front of screens i
mean it goes back to the idea that the
customer is always right if people spend
more time in front of the screen that
means they are having a good experience
uh mission accomplished
and this is an extremely poor
philosophical foundation
and i think that's the biggest problem
in silicon valley and in the entire
technological revolution that we are
seeing
that the technology and the engineering
is incredible
and the philosophy is sometimes very
childish indeed but
some people listening to this will go
okay you you've gone all philosophical
on us and um the world can't
yeah
we've got some bigger things to worry
about so so let's look at some of those
bigger things you know thinking as a
historian you said that we are
currently down to sort of no stories
that that old story of liberalism has
been broken by the sort of
disillusionment of the last couple years
so what now why does it matter that we
don't have a story now maybe we just
muddle along for a bit what happens what
are you worried about could happen
the worst problem is that we are
confronting uh some major global threats
and we need to act on them i mean if we
could have the time for you know a
couple of decades of just humanity on a
journey of soul-searching and who we are
and where do we go from here then fine
but we just don't have this luxury we
don't have the time we have climate
change we have the threat of nuclear war
still there people forgot oh it was in
the 60s no it's still today there are
still nukes around a lot of them
and we have this problem we've been
talking a lot about of disruptive
technologies
artificial intelligence disrupting the
job market the economy bioengineering
disrupting the human body itself
and we need global cooperation on all
these issues if we are to solve them or
to prevent the worst outcomes
and without a common story we don't have
global cooperation
again large-scale human cooperation is
built on shared stories and fictions and
mythologies and and you would include as
examples of that um everything from like
a a religion um maybe even a local
superstition through to
things like the american dream or or
even
human rights
human rights are not a biological fact
they are a story we have constructed
now when i say that something is a
fiction or a myth or a story it doesn't
mean that it's evil or that it's a lie
or that it is bad uh there are good
stories and bad stories i mean the way
to measure to decide whether a story is
good or bad is its impact in the world
some stories are wonderful
and some stories are terrible
but isn't like i think
one criticism i've occasionally heard of
your work is that there's like there's a
sort of breathtaking uh power in sort of
connecting
you know the fiction of human rights
with the fiction of believing in the god
gugu who is hidden behind that rock and
he was going to throw thunderbolts at
you
and both may have served a purpose in
their time but is it possible that
you're not doing enough to differentiate
different types of fiction that yes they
may all be useful in in their moment to
build cooperation but isn't it also
possible that some of these stories are
actually truer than others is that like
if you believe in truth
can't you also say that
stories
over time are at least capable of
becoming truer or more useful so for
example
science like i don't want to believe
that science is just another story no
science isn't i mean we need to
differentiate two types of power right
in history you have the power over
objective reality
like to build bridges or cure diseases
or building an atom bomb
and then you have the power over
humans and their subjective feelings
their imagination
making them believe in something
now for most
activities you need both
let's say you want to build an atom bomb
so on the one hand you need a good
theory of physics
if you don't understand physics well
enough you will not be able to build an
atom bomb and here we are not dealing
with fictional stories we are dealing
with more accurate or less accurate
scientific theories and i i definitely
believe in scientific objectivity and
truth in that sense
but on the other hand in order to build
an atom bomb
a good understanding of physics is not
enough
you also need people to cooperate
to mine uranium and build reactors and
and clean after you that all the
scientists have lunch so somebody needs
to clean the dishes you need people to
cooperate on this
and for that you need a story you will
not get millions of people cooperating
by telling them e equals m c square now
let's build an ad no wow
and the story you tell them need not be
true at all it could be complete
nonsense and still it would be effective
in making them cooperate now still i
would say there are good stories and bad
stories you can tell people in that
situation
the measurement would be
how much suffering
it causes or alleviates
so something therefore something like
human rights which is a human
construction and in one sense of fiction
but as measured by an attempt to
alleviate suffering is that it was a
very good story a really powerful story
yes not just powerful but but a very
good one but it's also dangerous to
confuse
a story we have constructed in a
particular historical setting and think
that we can just apply it
to any other historical period or to any
other political and geographical
location today in the world
yvonne why is it do you think that your
way of thinking about the world has
resonated so powerfully
in silicon valley like so many people i
know who are in the tech world
really view you as this
sort of
epic source of wisdom why do you think
that
i'm not sure i've heard several theories
some more flattering than others about
why this is the case well so here's a
possible flattering one and an
unflashing on the flattering one would
be that you're one of the few historians
who really seems to get technology and
the power of it so i think they respect
that
but perhaps the unflattering explanation
is that almost that you're
letting them
off the hook because you go with you
know
this is almost inevitable and our
response to it should be to
understand ourselves
better and then what happens next is not
clear whereas there's a lot of people
out there saying wait a sec you know the
world is about to be blown up by some of
the technologies we're doing shouldn't
you be calling for
a revolution calling for you know the
firewall to be erected around california
or
or something people are annoyed that you
are being too
calm in your recommendations about what
we should do usually i get the criticism
i'm far too pessimistic then and not
that i'm calm
but i i think that you you can't just
stop
all research and development of of
technology of ai of bioengineering and
even if you do it in one country
other countries will not do that so i i
don't think that we have the option of
just saying these developments are
extremely dangerous let's stop
one of the things you suggest we do is
to replace some of our
anger at the current situation with with
what you call bewilderment yeah
what did you mean by that
i mean that
when when when you're panicking or when
you're very angry you think you
understand what is happening
and
i think it's a better place to be in if
you realize wait a minute the truth is i
don't really understand
what is happening in the world
i don't have these ready-made answers
and part of the appeal of populists and
authoritarian
kind of father figures today is that
people are frightened are confused and
you have this person coming and saying i
know everything just trust in me i will
make everything okay and that's
extremely dangerous it's difficult but i
think it's important
to just stay with the bewilderment and
confusion not forever because we need to
take action but at least for for some
time
i mean there's a humility in that i
think isn't there like if everyone
on left and right for example instead of
getting
more and more outraged at each other we
just said actually i don't know the
answer to that and um i would like to
know like you could picture a shift in
tone of the conversation of people
trying to learn from each other instead
of trying to judge each other
i mean
do you see any chance of that happening
where actually are you on the optimism
pessimism um
spectrum i would try to kind of
summarize my my my
views like that
um
things today are better than ever for
humanity
things are still quite bad and things
can get much much worse
so i'm not an optimist because i think
that yes things are bad and they can get
much worse but i'm not a pessimist
either because i think that things are
better
than previously in history which means
that it is possible to improve the
situation
it's really still up to us we still have
the time and the ability to to make a
change and change for the better well
the stories we tell ourselves is going
to play a key part in that
what story would you like to inject into
the minds of people
listening that
might make a difference i would tell the
listeners that
there is now a race a competition to
hack humanity in general and to hack you
in particular
and
you should make the effort to stay ahead
of your competitors of the big
corporations the governments that are
trying to hack you
so you need to get to know yourself
better
uh because there are now these forces
that are trying to hack you it's not
like the old days you know philosophers
have been telling people to get to know
yourself better for thousands of years
but in the past in the days of socrates
or buddha you did not have real
competition
now you have competition you need to
stay ahead and
you know meditation is just one way to
do it for other people
psychological therapy works for some
people out
is the best way to get to know
themselves for some people sports or
taking a long hike whatever works for
you
invest in that do that because you must
stay ahead of the competition if they
get to know you better than you know
yourself it's game over for you and
if i might add evolving one thing i've
learned from you is just how much
narratives matter
and it feels like that there's so many
narratives going around today that we
are telling ourselves
that aren't helping humans cooperate
better they're actually quite
destructive
um
[Music]
any advice for people on how to pay
attention to the narratives in your mind
and maybe
improve those
narratives to avoid that risk
that goes back to the to the first
suggestion of getting to know yourself
better because getting to know yourself
better often means getting to know the
stories in your mind
the stories could be personal stories
about your own life and childhood and
personality and whatever and they could
be
religious and nationalist and
ideological stories
and if you really take the time
to get to know the stories inside
yourself and what they are doing to you
i think this is kind of the best
inoculation
against the worst stories around because
the stories that harm
humanity
usually start by harming you
that
they kind of amplify turn up the volume
of the angry voices in your mind in your
head they turn up the volume of the
fearful voices in your head and fear and
anger and hatred
they harm you long before they harm
anybody else
if you walk around all day with all
these hateful and fearful voices in your
mind this destroys your peace of mind
long before it harms anybody else
and we are living in a world where there
are many people and many organizations
that try to send their hand into our
brain and find the the volume button and
put up the volume of the hate
and of the fear voices and if you can
actually see it happening and what it
does to you that's the best defense
against these external hands that are
being sent all the time into your brain
into your mind
well you are um what an amazing
conversation thank you so much for this
this time and for all your thinking
about this here's hoping for
i don't know a wiser future with better
stories told thanks so much yvonne thank
you
[Music]
okay that's a wrap for this episode do
consider writing a brief review of the
ted interview on apple itunes or
wherever you listen to podcasts those
reviews are influential actually and we
certainly read every word
this show was produced by sharon mashihi
our editorial director is michelle quint
production manager is roxanne high lash
mix engineer david hermann and our theme
music is by alison leighton brown
thanks for listening
on the next episode best-selling author
johann hari
he shares his personal experience with
depression and his journey to discover
both its causes and solutions
it is not the trauma that destroys you
it is the shame about the trauma and
giving people safe places to release
that shame
is an antidepressant
that's next time on the ted interview
[Music]